so hi and welcome to another episode of
biographics I am your interim host Carl
Smallwood and today we're talking about
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle the creator of
Sherlock Holmes and the original article
which you can no doubt find linked below
is by one Larry H
ers
in November
37 the popular paperback magazine
beaton's Christmas annual introduced the
new character to the world of crying
fiction his name was Sherlock Holmes
along with his newly met random roommate
Dr John Watson Holmes moved Mount
contemporary London visiting sites and
using conveyances familiar to his
readers as he tackle the mystery Watson
called a study in Scarlet this is Hand
of the Baskervilles I I do have a study
in Scala but it's part of a compilation
so the title would be different so just
pretend that this is a study in Scarlet
okay let's go on
though the story received positive
reviews from some critics it did not
sell particularly well later published
in a harbor volume its sales too were
disappointing it was not the first work
published by its author physician and
ophthalmologist named Arthur Conan Doyle
who had written the novel in just three
weeks they all had by then been
published professionally in trade and
fiction yeah Holmes was the introduction
of a character which transcended the
literary world not merely in crime
fiction but in all forms of literature
chat literature
literally from that inauspicious
beginning Sherlock Holmes grew into
International Fame he brought the crater
great wealth and Renown but he also
brought his creator frustrations to the
point that Doyle attempted to kill the
great detective and it's about public
pressure and resurrect him Arthur Conan
Doyle wrote prolifically on a diverse
range of subjects yet today with the
possible exception of his 1912 science
fiction novel The Lost World is
remembered almost entirely for Sherlock
Holmes the home store is 56 short
stories and four novels remain his
legacy his other works largely forgotten
it is a legacy which he feared and
worked to prevent throughout his career
that career began in the slums of
Edinburgh Scotland by its end he had
achieved some success in medicine failed
in politics studied the occult and
spiritualism hey we've all been there
became a noted author and published
prodigiously yet he's remembered for
Holmes it was a fate he feared and
stroll to avoid most of his life
Arthur Ignatius Conan Doyle Ignatius
that's a name does anyone remember
nightmare creatures like Ignatius and
his big staff like doing like werewolf
combos anyway
he was born May 22nd 1859 in Edinburgh
his father supported the large family by
working as an illustrator and released
steadily worsening alcoholism led him to
be institutionalized the family
splintered for a time to be reunited in
the tenements though not with Arthur but
the age of nine Doyle with the financial
assistance of relatives went to England
to study first under the Jesuits a
hotter place then at stonyhurst College
in later life he spoke of his Early
Education in harsh terms condemning the
discipline applied by the Jesuit
principles as well as the course of
study in 1875 Doyle was sent to Austria
to study in the Jesuit school Stella
machitina Doyle returned to Britain in
1876 studying medicine at the University
of Edinburgh he remained at the school
until 1881 while there he began to write
and in 1879 his first published short
story The Mystery of the cesara valley
appeared in a local magazine featuring a
South African Valley dominated by a
vengeful Spirit the story was published
anonymously during the course of his
studies Dayal served as a shit's
physician on a whaling vessel he later
used use his shipboard experience in his
writing in 1881 he took his degrees of
Bachelor of medicine and master of
surgery and returned to the Sea as a
ship's doctor for a voyage to West
Africa and finally in 1885 received his
degree as a doctor of medicine after a
brief partnership in a private practice
with a former classmate Diana
established his own practice in
Portsmouth in 1882.
foreign
late for perusing the canvases this is
not miss Belvedere
Mr Holmes
no
it's impossible improbable my lady but
not impossible I don't understand how
you're here Mr Holmes I've been keeping
track of your internet history purchases
and online activity if you'd booked a
flight or transport or anything I would
have known and that was your biggest
mistake Miss Belvedere for you see my
browsing history has never been safer as
of late thanks to nordvpn the sponsors
of today's video
I reserved my flight to this gallery
from a completely different country far
away from your prying eyes much safer
and much cheaper how is that possible
well you see Miss Belvedere many
companies vary the price of their
products based on several factors such
as the location of their business the
location of the customer or fluctuations
in local and foreign currencies by using
norvpn to connect a service outside of
your own country you can browse other
markets and find the cheapest price
available you misunderstand me Mr Holmes
how did you do decide which VPN service
to use well nordvpn is the swiftest
virtual private Network on the planet
offering a safer browsing experience
with a single click if will take a
billion computers a billion years to
decrypt my browsing data not only that
with no vpn's threat protection feature
I'm also shielded from everyday online
cyber threats such as malware and
trackers
Please Mr Holmes I have no interest in
hearing about nordvpn's security
features oh then perhaps you'd be more
interested in hearing how you can use
nordvpn to ensure you never miss out on
your favorite online content even here
far away from my beloved Baker Street I
can still watch my favorite shows
whenever I please
just arrest me oh it's very arresting
isn't it check out nordvpn and get four
months extra on a two-year plan by going
to nordvpn.com forward slash buyer
that's northvpn.com forward slash bio if
you are not 100 satisfied with the
service get in touch within 30 days of
your purchase date and get a full refund
isn't that right Miss Belvedere
blast not again
[Music]
those through hard work and Word of
Mouth among these patients dialed
Medical Practice gradually brought
insufficient in Comfort to live in a
reasonable Comfort one of his patients
introduced dial to her sister Louisa
Hawkins though Louisa suffered from an
then unknown illness Doyle found her
amiable and they were married in 1885.
who says that romance is dead now with
the wife's support dial sold his first
Holmes novel a studying Scarlet remember
we're pretending that Hound of the
Baskervilles is the study of scarlet the
second half of the novel setting in the
American West were heavily influenced by
the American novelist Bret Hart one of
Donald's favorite writers the character
of Sherlock Holmes though was based
primarily on one of Donald's Edinburgh
teachers Dr Joseph Bell who demonstrated
the power of observation in deductive
reasoning Doyle attributed to the great
detective the relationship was so clear
that Robert Louis Stevenson a friend of
dials and another of bell students wrote
to the author saying in part and I quote
can this be my old friend Joe Bell
Holmes was not an overnight sensation
though the short stories featuring him
sold well enough to lead to a meeting
with an American publisher Joseph
Lippincott after dinner in London's
Langham Hotel a site that would later
feature in several Hans stories
Lippincott entertained dial and another
English author whose popularity was on
the rise in the United States Oscar
Wilde two novels were commissioned a lot
memorable dinner the sign of four a home
story and The Picture of Dorian Gray the
only novel Oscar Wilde ever wrote the
sign of four was moderately successful
but Doyle was growing Restless in his
practice and in his writing success
which was limited to the most part to
Sherlock Holmes Stories the birth of his
first daughter Mary Louise in 1889
served as another spur to die on he went
to Vienna leaving his family in
Portsmouth to study Ophthalmology after
which he opened a practice in London in
windpole Street Louisa and Mary joined
him soon thereafter he did not Thrive as
an eye doctor though in the bustling
city of London despite a desire to be
seen as a serious historical writer
Doyle found little interest in his work
other than continued steady sales of
Holmes novels rather an approach his
previous Publishers Doyle contacted the
editor of the popular strand magazine
the first of a short stories featuring
Sherlock Holmes appeared in strand in
July 1891 titled A study in Bohemia five
more followed published consecutively in
monthly editions by the close of 1899 on
Sherlock Holmes Dr Watson 22 1B Baker
Street and Arthur Conan Doyle himself
were famous around the British Empire
and in the United States strand magazine
commission a follow-up of six stories
Dale turns attention to writing full
time the stories in strand magazine
which were illustrated by one Sydney
Packer produced a tall spare Pike
smoking icon which has been the image of
Holmes ever since
foreign
in the spring of 1891 Doyle made the
decision to sell his medical practice
abandon medicine altogether and pursue
writing as his full-time vocation though
the success of the Holmes character
which allowed him to do so he had no
intention of focusing all of his efforts
on stories of the great detective he
pursued all the areas of literature
including historical fiction and tales
of the supernatural one of his many
interests one of his earliest short
stories J habercook jeffan's statement
written in 1884 covered the story of the
Mary Celeste though in a fictional tale
Doyle wanted to continue with other
stories in the same vein however his
fans wanted homes and the more homes the
better Doyle placed homes in London
which is to say in the London and Empire
of his readers londoners knew the
neighborhood Holmes new the restaurants
and hotels the theaters the museums the
railroad stations and schedules they
read the same newspaper Holmes read
attended the same concerts watched the
same place the reader's Holmes was a
contemporary a neighbor a subject of the
same Monarch his fans flocked to Baker
Street its neighborhood and the
Alleyways and news which the historical
detective followed his Quarry they
couldn't get enough of him in 1892
Louisa gave birth to the couple's second
child a son which they named Arthur oh
not just Arthur though Arthur Arlene
Kingsley Doyle again a very strong name
his growing family and wealth made by
all increasingly Restless he began to
cast about ways to rid himself of the
fictional detective which had led to his
success having freed himself from his
medical career to devote his full-time
attention to writing he felt the need to
free himself from the literary hero he
had created Doyle wanted to concentrate
on writings about the supernatural as
well as historical fiction and Holmes
simply took up too much of his time
following the birth of his son he
traveled to the continent visiting sites
in Austria France Italy and Switzerland
during the visit he saw in Switzerland
the waterfalls at Reichenbach whether he
had consciously already decides to kill
Sherlock Holmes or if the idea was
inspired by the falls is not known
whatever the case he had signaled his
intent to rid himself the character
including writing to his mother and I
quote I am thinking of slaying Holmes he
had also complained to his editors at
strand magazine the character distracted
public attention from his other works
worst problems to have the way in an
attempt to discourage strand Magazine
from publishing Further Adventures of
Sherlock Holmes dial demanded higher and
higher rates for his stories to add to
his frustration the magazine willingly
agreed to pay them again worst problems
to have despite the lucrative nature of
the character and the stories featuring
him they all considered his other works
to be more interesting and better in
terms of his writing in short he
believed horns have become a trap
preventing him from more serious and
satisfying literary Pursuits at any rate
in December 1893 strand magazine
published a home short story the 24th in
the series titled quite fittingly an
ironically given hindsight the final
problem at the end of the story Dr
Watson infers from the evidence he sees
that Sherlock Holmes grappled with his
arch enemy Professor Moriarty on the
ledge above the Reichenbach Falls and
both men had tumbled over the edge to
their deaths far below public reaction
to the death of Sherlock Holmes was
immediate and negative strand Magazine's
subscription numbers plummeted nearly as
quickly as Holmes had her over twenty
thousand subscribers canceled or failed
to renew their subscriptions Doyle
didn't care he turned his attention to
writing short stories and novels
including those featuring a new
character Brigadier Gerard a vain
pompous soldier in Napoleon's armies
Gerard related the short stories himself
in the Viewpoint of an old retired
Soldier reminiscing over his days as the
greatest Soldier and gentleman of his
time Doyle eventually wrote about 17
short stories featuring Gerard for
strand magazine as well as a play and a
novel that the critics received them
well but do not generate a large fan
base you can see where this is going
right Doyle traveled extensively during
this period to the continent to what was
then called the East meaning Egypt and
to the United States for a lecture tour
in 1894 appearing in over 30 cities the
worsening of his wife's condition
finally diagnosed as tuberculosis led
him to travel to warmer climates in
hopes he would ease her suffering and
she became his patient rather than his
partner in 1897 dial met a young woman
called Gene Leckie they began a discrete
Affair though Doyle insisted the
relationship remained a platonic one
while his first wife was alive
[Music]
in 1900 Doyle despite the misgivings
family volunteered for military service
in the Boer War offering his Services as
a physician though he served at blow
Fontaine for just a few months what he
saw there led him to produce two works
on the war and Britain's role in South
Africa he defended the British actions
there when he wrote The Great boar War a
non-fiction account of the conflict
published in 1900 at the time the
British public believed the war to be
over though in fact it dragged on for
another two years on his return to
England they all stood for Parliament
and though he was not a practicing
Catholic his Jesuit education was
exploited by his opponents depicted as a
bigger loyal to the pope Doyle lost his
campaign in Edinburgh in 1900 he ran
again six years later in Harwick Bergs
there he lost again in between dials
knighted In 1902 at the coronation
honors receiving his award from King
Edward VII in October booking on Palace
from that point on he styled himself as
Sir Arthur Conan Dion by then dial would
return to Sherlock Holmes in 1901 he
published a new home story as a novel
though it first appeared as a serial in
strand magazine over the course of a
year don't deliberately set the story
before the events of the Reichenbach
Falls and moved most of the stories
outside of London to the Moors of
Devonshire this story was well received
by his readers and though he continued
to write prolifically on other subjects
Doyle finally bowed the pressure from
his readers and Publishers and
resurrected homes the short story The
Adventure of the empty house appeared in
strand magazine in October 1903 after
first appearing in the American Colliers
the preceding month in it Holmes
explains to Watson that he had faked his
own death and remained Incognito to
confound his other enemies they all
continued to produce home storage for
the rest of his career the last
appearing is strand magazine in April
1927. he experiments with the format
from time to time with Holmes relating a
story on his own without Watson making
appearance but most retained his tried
and true format with Watson the loyal
associate of the two adventurers dealt
with deadly assailants hidden intent and
blundering policemen despite the success
of the home stories Doyle continued to
pursue other literary interests writing
multitudes of short stories and novels
which although selling well continues to
be dwarf by Sherlock Holmes in 1906
Louisa died passing away at home on July
4th the following year dial married Gene
Leckie on September 18 1907. his
children from his first marriage and his
new bride moved into a Sussex mansion He
had helped design which he named wyndall
sham he remained his home for the rest
of his life though he maintained
apartments in London for his use during
its standard stays in the city his
second marriage was a happy one and Gina
Sir Arthur had three children together
following his second marriage dialed
literary output slow though it was still
prodigious devoted to his family he
brought them along on his many travels
whenever possible he continued to invent
new characters and bills series around
them including Professor Edward
Challenger Challenger made his first
appearance in a science fiction fantasy
novel which Doyle published in 1912 The
Lost World the novel featured a
previously unknown South American
Plateau populated with
Dinosaurs yeah dinosaurs
why is it just yeah that's right bring
some dinosaurs in and other early
hominids they all provide a challenger
with a temperament the opposite of harms
and featured the character in three
novels and a pair of short stories he
also posed for a portrait of Challenger
which he wanted strand magazine to run
with a serialized version of The Lost
World the magazine demured that the
photo was used for the first hardbound
edition of the book in 1912.
[Music]
throughout his life Arthur Conan Doyle
was known in his day as an avid
Sportsman he was a devotee of boxing
played Cricket enjoy golf befitting for
a Scotsman was an early propellant of
the spot of bodybuilder an amateur boxer
he turned down an invitation to referee
a heavyweight championship fight between
Jack Johnson and James Jeffries in 1910
the fight was held in Reno Nevada and
dialysis himself based on the distance
he would have to travel yet he loved to
travel in the company of his family and
made numerous excursions by ship and
train to the United States Canada and
the continent he also became an early
supporter of the automobile when love to
drive is increasingly powerful and fast
cars unlike most gentlemen of his wealth
and social standing they all prefer to
drive himself rather than employ a
chauffeur many of his sporting tastes
appeared in Sherlock Holmes from the
beginning Sherlock Holmes exhibited
extraordinary strength and skills in
boxing and Arcane wrestling holes noted
Fighters appeared in several Hans
Adventures Holmes introduced himself as
a bare knuckle boxer to another fighter
in the sign of four he created escape
from Moriarty above the Reichenbach
falls to his knowledge of the Japanese
science of wrestling homes called
balitsu The Adventure of the empty house
the famed detective also expressed a
lively interest in horse racing cricket
and other sporting Pursuits all of these
reflected the interests of his creator
as events on the European continent led
to increased tensions which gradually
erupted into the first world war Holmes
was drawn in with stories reflecting his
involvement with the government officers
during the war they all traveled to the
Western Front publishing articles and
books which explained the fighting to
his readers often in a manner critical
of British military leadership in 1917
with the war raging dial published his
final collection of Home stories
properly titled his last battle an
introduction to collection purportedly
written by Dr Watson assured his readers
that Holmes were living in retirement
oh this is a fun pie note I know this
bit another trait of dials which Holmes
did not adopt was a traitor's growing
interest in the occult tragic events
during the war that affected him
personally only served to increase those
interests Doyle's first son Kingsley was
wounded severely at the Somme and died
of complications of pneumonia while
being hospitalized for his wounds in
addition to the loss of his son Doyle's
brother eens and his brother-in-law and
two of his nephews fell on the Western
Front dial felt the losses acutely
following World War one he focused
heavily on spiritualism seances and
trance writing and he addressed these in
similar subjects in his work the
tragedies he suffered during the war as
well as the death of his first wife no
doubt stimulated his interest it led to
the church announcing his works and to
increase mockery in the British tabloid
press his belief in life after death and
the ability of some gifted Sidekicks to
spam the distance between the living and
the dead led to numerous articles essays
and books on the subject which he
supported by lecture tours and speech
features this brought in considerable
disdain from Skeptics for example a 1920
tour of Austria New Zealand as a
spiritualist missionary led to outright
mockery in the Press yet he continued on
certain of his beliefs even as psychic
after psychic many of whom he publicly
endorsed were revealed as fraud his
friendship with famed Illusionist Harry
Houdini came to an abrupt end when the
magician exposed several seances as
fraud and described the methods used by
the purported psychics and it was
defense of spiritualists and psychic
mediums isolated him from many of his
former friends and colleagues and
brought him considerable ridicule on his
writings they all spent over a quarter
of a million pounds in his mission
supporting spiritualism he continued to
produce short stories and one final
novel featuring Sherlock Holmes the
final home story appearing in 1927. by
then four novels and 56 short stories
made up the Sherlock Holmes Canon and me
a fraction of Doyle's literary output
there are also several plays for the
stage and for the motion picture camera
on July 7 1930 Arthur Conan Doyle died
from heart disease while at home at
windlesham he was 71 he had suffered
several attacks of chest pain during the
preceding Autumn when he undertook a
tour promoting spiritualism in Europe
exhausted by the tour he began 1930
confined to his bet only able to rise
and sit in a chair for short periods one
day in the spring he arose and went for
a walk in his garden or he's found
clutching his chest with one hand and a
crocus in the other returning to his bed
he leaned good for a time before he's
coming with his family surrounding him
his renunciation of Christianity raised
shall we say complications regarding his
burial his funeral on July 11 ended with
his internment in his own garden at
Windle Shan after his wife John died in
1940 Doyle's body was interred next to
her in a churchyard in minstead New
Forest Hampshire none of Donald's
children had children of their own and
after the 1997 death of his daughter
Jean Lennon no direct descendants of the
prolific writer and sportsman remained
though he published over 200 short
stories and magazine articles 23 novels
13 plays Four volumes of poetry 10
full-length books of non-fiction or 13
books on spiritualism with an additional
10 pamphlets on the subject based on his
lectures Doyle is largely remembered for
Sherlock Holmes as he feared during his
lifetime his great detective
overshadowed his own literary
achievements today 22 1B Bakery is a
museum dedicated to Holmes and Watson a
statue of Home standing Edinburgh near
the birthplace of his creator
additionally exhibitions of the sitting
rooms occupied by Holmes and wat Center
in Switzerland and London a Swiss Museum
dedicated to Harmony located near
Reichenbach Falls the Portsmouth City
Museum located near where Doyle lived
and worked early in his career is
dedicated to the author and his most
enduring character even in death Arthur
Conan Doyle cannot be truly separated
from Holmes and Watson and the befalled
London streets they prowled urged on by
the mystery they were determined to
solve numerous other writes have taken
up the Holmes mantle in film television
novel short stories games and other
media but for Arthur Conan dial Dr
Watson Professor Moriarty Colonel Moran
and the hellhound of the Devonshire
Moors and all of the authors of the
Creations remain his legacy forever
entwined with literature's greatest
fictional Detective Sherlock Holmes
as noted this was an article by one
Larry H so shout out to them for writing
this and thanks once again if you're
wondering who the hell are you and Carl
Smallwood I used to write for biographic
sister site top tens many years ago and
have my own channel fact fiend with Cal
small which you can no doubt found
linked below somewhere cheers for
everyone for watching this um leave a
like comment subscribe all that good
stuff and have the day you deserve